it is to the philippines now where
today's presidential election has a
clear favorite ferdinand marcus jr now
the name marcus is synonymous with
corruption and human rights abuses of
the country the family of the former
philippine dictator has worked steadily
on his comeback over the past decades
and so ferdinand marcus jr could soon
follow in his infamous father's
footsteps one reason for this the ever
widening gap between the rich and the
poor in 2020 the philippines saw the
worst recession in more than 50 years
gdp growth fell by almost 10 points year
on year
now the economy is slowly recovering in
2021 it grew by about five and five and
a half percent compared to the
disastrous year before now the hugely
important tourism sector has
particularly been hit to date many
holiday makers are staying away the
results companies are shutting down
incomes are dropping
unemployment and inflation have been
rising sharply in addition the state's
debt has grown because of high costs to
combat the pandemic but
there's hope here's more from dw's
janelle de malo
if numbers are anything to go by there's
reason to be optimistic about the
philippine economy
we have vaccinated
a really a significant number of
filipinos which is manifesting now
because we have a very low case counts
and because of this one we are able to
liberally open our economy in fact we're
expecting seven percent annual growth
but inflation and unemployment keep
filipinos from feeling that recovery in
the run-up to election day voters were
promised that propelling their supported
candidate to the presidency would change
that
the price of goods will fall the price
of electricity will fall of water of
everything for the poor
the so-called build build build
infrastructure program will give people
a lot of jobs
with this next president we hope for
lower costs for things like transport
boosting employment and raining and
living costs aren't the only tasks for
the country's new leader
many promises were made from supporting
small businesses and investing in
education
the incoming government now has six
years to prove that it will be able to
turn promises into policy not only for
its supporters but for the 110 million
or so filipinos it will be tasked with
governing
let's get the latest from dw
correspondent janel de malon whose
report you just saw janelle you've been
focusing on ferdinand or bongbong marcus
uh there mainly uh in your report he's
been polling ahead in the past weeks
will he be able to deliver on the
promises that he made like lowering
prices for example
well i think one of the reasons that he
is a front runner in the first place is
his ability to make these populist
promises for example he says things like
when i'm president the price of a kilo
of rice will only be up to this certain
low amount and that certain low amount
is an amount that would [ __ ] farmers
for instance so he is able to uh
make promises that play well with the
public but aren't particularly
practicable so his campaign has focused
on really gut issues like the rising
cost of living like lowering electricity
but really what he is doing is providing
a vague notion of what he's able to
achieve he's making it seem more
straightforward than it actually is and
people seem to be buying it especially
in these pandemic times
at the same time let's talk about the
other candidate here lenny robrito he's
been the favorite of the business
community tell us why
she is a trained economist that she is a
lawyer she's perceived to have what it
takes to be able to run an economy and
just in general her agenda and her
platform has been a lot more detailed
and a lot more transparent she has
published plans as to how to boost
fisheries and in industries like
fisheries and agriculture how to expand
the social net how to
promote the digital economy whereas
bongbong marcus's uh platform has been a
bit more a bit more vague as i was
saying earlier he also doesn't submit
these policies up to scrutiny
for example he doesn't join presidential
debates he doesn't answer the questions
of journalists so it's really hard to
know what he is thinking when it comes
to the economy really and as we know
businesses they don't like uncertainty
and they don't like being not being able
to see through to him
janelle do you see the outcome of this
election materially affecting people in
an economy where unemployment is rising
where prices are rising
well it passed this prologue kristoff
it's really hard to say before any
outcome has been determined but i am
standing in ilocos norte where what
which is the whole region of bong bong
marcus he was governor here for a long
time and it remains one of the poorest
regions in the philippines if that is
what we're going by then i don't know if
he has what it takes to run the entire
philippine economy
janelle de malon thank you for your
assessment there
you